j'ai le plaisir de recevoir les membres
du groupe mythique sénégalais à l'âme un
groupe d'ong présentes puis en afrique
en tout cas mais c'est un auditeur c'est
un téléspectateur c'est un de nos
fidèles vont découvrir alors c'est un
groupe qui existe depuis très longtemps
d'abord j'ai pas je puisse le parfaire
le travail présentation de la place
qu'ils vont le faire
g tapha de ce côté bonjour tapha harry
bonjour et souleymane faye voilà bonjour
dites-moi ce groupe dont on parle depuis
quand même très longtemps ce groupe-là
alam 2
vous êtes à la bulle et ce à la main
comment est ce qu'il a vu le jour
il a vu le jour dans les années 70 sans
fatigue en 1069 dans les environs de
sang neuf et pourquoi ça s'appellera en
deux parce qu'à cette époque il y avait
un premier groupe qui s'appelle quitté
de nous est né quitté des musiciens de
cul faisaient de la variété c'était des
grands musiciens de variétés comme il en
existait dans les années 60 et nous en
fait on a hérité un peu de leur
instrument c'était ça le ram 2 c'est
comme le les équipes de football les
seniors et les juniors ce sera les
petits frères qui altèrent comme les
grands on a hérité mais notre vision
n'était pas la même a dit que nous ne
trouve notre vision c'était de créer une
musique qui nous est propre
qu'ils soient y aller allons y aller une
musique originale on apparaître parce
que on regardait beaucoup les autres
groupes qui carton est déjà allé au 6
bis allée ferrat au c est que c est
magnifique on aimerait bien être comme
eux et c'est ça qui a amené l'idée de la
création du groupe qui a évolué de la
variété à la création de cette musique
qui existe et suleiman quelles ont été
vos premières inspirations ou le style
que vous avez voulu vraiment à voir
qu'il faut que vous sa propre à vous en
faites beaucoup sur
la musique et serrières passe un peu à
l'aise ses musiques larguèze rock blues
quand je pense musique je bascule à la
porte et en même temps vous avez eu
tapha vous avez eu un style de mbalax
qui est quand même assez un style assez
particulier qui a on va dire redonner un
nouveau souffle à ce style traditionnel
sénégalais oui parce qu'en fait le mot
la c1 c'est en rythmique
d'accompagnement qui est sénégalais est
dans le style local
il ya une façon de jouer a que les
sénégalais qui peuvent rentrer là dedans
et nous quand on est revenu on a voulu
ouvrir ses bagages la ccvla à tout le
monde pour que ce soit accessible en
fait c'est souvent là que le fallait
rejouer dans le bal à jusqu'aujourd'hui
les goûts traditionnels font la valeur
qui est vraiment compris que par les
séries et voilà c'est la seule
différence parce que nous allons faire
des mots sur tout le monde en parle mal
à jouer et ils entendent lobala et le
mot l'art traditionnel c'est vraiment là
devant les savants vous vous entendu
parfois jouer mais avec une certaine
ouverture musicalité c'est ça et ça
c'est un arrêt ça c'est votre base
musicale donc c'est votre style qu'on va
considérer comme un con c'est comme le
style à l'amci c'est exactement ce à
dire que comme dit à fars nous on a
beaucoup travaillé sur des rythmiques
qui existent un peu partout au sénégal
parce que c'est pas on part du lard ou
du sabar mais dans le sud du sénégal il
ya les et nicolas qui utilisent des
drogues au bout d une sorte d' ensemble
de percussions et demi qu'on laisse
maintenant en fait qui est plus musical
que le sabre et rythmiques et on a
travaillé beaucoup sur ces aspects là
pour créer une musique et la constance
c'est que quand vous jouez mal aussi
c'est que ça cause dès que ça sonne et
soirées gays soient sanctionnés funky
et donc les gens disaient mais disons
mais c'est funky mais on sait s p sur le
rythme de base si on revient un peu à
l'histoire comme la musique brésilienne
quoi que ce soit on se dit que nous les
origines on va les réviser tes la preuve
on a fait des festivals de jazz un peu
partout dans le monde et les murs on
atterrit beaucoup les musiciens de jazz
parce que de la fusion qu'on arrivait à
faire pour eux c'est une sorte de retour
aux sources
on a fait des diamants avec dizzy
gillepsie sonny rollins des miles davis
et tout quand on en parle comme ça les
indices
et pourtant il ya des preuves ya des
enregistrements enlève où il venait
faire des gammes sur une musique en
disant que c'est c'est magnifique c'est
une belle fusion alors vous êtes avec
comme en studio vous êtes juste 3 mais
en fait le groupe beaucoup plus gros que
ça vous êtes combien au total en ce
moment et vous composez comment passer
quand on parle de cette fusion de ses
influences l'alger très curieux la
d'entrer dans votre cuisine interne
comment commence à ceux du moment qu'on
vit ensemble à jeu vous permet de venir
lui convenir ensemble on travaille tout
temps où les idées elles viennent
pendant très longtemps en fait on s'est
partagé les droits parce que les idées
et peut venir d'une harmonie ou bien
d'un texte vraiment ludique et et ça se
cuisine comme ça le percussionniste dit
moi je vois ça comme ça en fait c'est un
travail de longue haleine mais quand il
est posé il est vraiment posé tout le
monde y participe
c'est pas seulement moi je viens je
compose la rythmique les harmonies les
mérites non je peux ramener l'harmonie
l'autre à mai 2010 le drame et la
rythmique et ça fait la cuisine de femme
sexy musique collective avec des
individualités exemple les textes ghana
où il ya beaucoup de textes je dis que
les gens écoutent dans leur langue qui
les intéresse c'est seulement que ces
textes et la musique au niveau des
doigts sénégal compte du challenge
morano penser ainsi de suite la
rythmique parce que moi je te laisse
donc toutes les pertes du jour toutes
les paires que c'est pour moi les
godasses n'émouvait là où les
traditionnelles et où donc il ya tout ce
mélange là qui fait que quand on fait un
morceau tout de suite les gens ne vont
pas descendre ceux de ta part
c'est très bien et ça nécessite aussi de
votre part beaucoup de collaborations
beaucoup de on va dire beaucoup de
respect des uns des autres parce que
souvent les groupes bien on est des
êtres vous en vous et des artistes vous
êtes vedette ilya légaux donc pour
pouvoir faire tout ce que vous faites là
et survivre ça signifie qu'avant quelque
part il ya il faut qu'ils aient un
minimum de respect entre vous sur les
mains oui au fait au moyeu il fait
partie de ceux qui sont le dernier
voulait attendre ou donc méthane suivie
vue il trouve une famille 3e il se noue
famille d'esprit de famille a
l'impression d'être dans une maison de
famille donc ça c'est que serveuse alors
vous en parle beaucoup de votre
rythmique et quand vous écoutez ça qui
frappe
on a pas on ne peut pas rester couchés
dans vos écoutant on a toujours envie de
bouger et vous avez commencé dans les
années 80 où il y avait beaucoup de
musiciens beaucoup de groupes engagés
est ce que vous le plan politique vous
avez aussi un petit peu joué là dessus
bien vous êtes resté plus à un retrait
lui je vais parler aujourd'hui est ce
que les textes de deux rames déjà de
musique allemand déjà on a révolutionné
la musique chez nous parce que les
musiciens ont tendance à jouer des
musiques qui sont basés plutôt à l'offre
dakar mme allard marc valleur donc on a
plain détenus évadés rythmique qui sont
des rythmiques est différente d'autres
et nous ce qu'on a fait d'abord la
révolution c'est de pouvoir mélanger ça
ou bien de privilégier une région qui
était sous représentée et donc les
textes aussi douce les manque de contenu
chanteurs sont toujours très engagé
nos textes c'est l'amour où on va parler
morale pas moral mais on s'engage on
dénonce à la manière comme il le fait
lui à la manière de jean la fontaine où
je donnais ethnies on nous avons
beaucoup de deux choses comme ça par
exemple quand on veut virer le monsieur
qui président la maison simple
donc c'est beaucoup de métal se dit
juste pour parler de l'engagement
oui aujourd'hui c'est vrai que la
libération de mandela
les artistes ont beaucoup ont beaucoup
contribué au drame des clés qu'on était
arrivé le premier album que nous avons
fait ça s'appelait gaulle et j'espère
bien sûr bien sûr ben quand on a décoré
les gens ils disaient mais nous disait
mais c'est pas vendeur vous me racontez
des histoires des esclaves c'était notre
histoire qu'il fallait le premier album
professionnel en europe
c'était la bourgogne et finalement c'est
un désaveu qui est le plus respecté du
feu à la mousse qu'aujourd'hui le goal
août devrait suivre la daube suivante
ça s'appelait alors que c'était l'époque
donc puis on a eu la chance aussi ils
ont eu la chance il y avait le groupe de
nick l'ex avocat qui estime qu'ils
étaient allés mais après un album et des
rentrées chez elles abandonnées et nous
on sortait l'album apartheid dont cris
la même maison gollnisch en asie ligue 1
il ya un gouffre sud africain qui est là
ils ont fait un aveu qui rentrent
est-ce que ça serait pas facile père est
parti ils ont fait la prière partout
sanguinaire et ça fait boum pour eux car
combat marée avec des vagues comme ça
dans l'histoire
ils ont fait qu'ils étaient là pour
faire vingt minutes on les a laissé
jouer une au cirque d'hiver pendant
quatre jours parce qu'on pourrait pas
l'aider descendait puisqu'ils ont
explosé passant alors un moment donné où
vous avez disparu de la scène au plus
grand désespoir de vos fans bon dieu
merci vous êtes la devise est de retour
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez disparu tu as un
moment donné on n'a pas disparu
[Musique]
vo on s'est connus quand ils avaient 15
16 17 ans et 30 ans 35 ans de vie
commune les gens avaient à l'idée
d'aller voir ailleurs ou bien des mets
et puis quand vous vivez en france un
certain moment il y en a certains qui
voulaient repartir au sénégal pour
d'autres expériences sont bien et c'est
ça et donc c'est une grosse journée des
familles voilà on habitait ensemble
composé une pause d'un an deux ans elle
imposera du débutant
c'est ça c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est
du pouce et à certains moments on a
repris mais comme ça instinctivement
ok c'est appeler chacun à eu d'autres
aventures c'était important pour nous
aussi un moment donné la pause parce que
vivre pendant 25 ans entre dans la même
maison
il fallait aller voir les hawks étaient
arrivés juste naturellement mais je ne
me sentais pas parce qu'il y avait des
querelles au contraire parce qu'on y
voit des bateaux qui étaient quand même
très important dans gouttes donc on
change tout allocataire à moi de vous
les faire respirer un peu chacun a fondé
une famille il avait son projet qui a
créé une belle saveur lui et il
s'appelle désert tout se passe là bas
moi je suis parti aux états unis avec
jean luc ponty pendant 15 ans coundoul a
participé avec d'autres sciences lehmann
était devenu incontournable à exactement
naturellement on a envie de le prendre
[Rires]
mais surtout plaît vraiment la merde
tout ce que j'ai fait donc tout ça on
s'est dit bon allez on reprend les
là ou quoi c'est comme ça s'est fait
naturellement tout naturellement et rien
n'a changé le premier concert qu'on a
fait après huit ans les en fait de la
salle était comble avec debbie tellement
cher au sénégal woods faisait jamais
dévié colza mais les gens venaient pas
que c'était pour voir est ce qu'on va
nous jouer des choses parce que y aller
il ya des comme on appelait ça des gens
les plus réduits on a bouge pas c'est ça
les nostalgiques
ils veulent revivre ce qu'ils ont
connues et dans la vérité est qu'on a
connus ici qu'ils étaient étudiants dans
les années 85 restants du sénégal qui
sont venus comme ça et il a eu une étude
maintenance de sa condamnation mais on
est devenu des années même et puis il y
avait toute une jeunesse pendant cette
période-là qui écoutait le travail ils
ont jamais vu là jamais et il
connaissait à l'époque n'avait pas
youtube à deux pas de vignes ou grippe
et tous dans un registre où les rennais
il ne connaissait pas la rue nous on
n'avait pas beaucoup de jeu parfait
qu'il savait pas et il y avait des
jeunes cantine double ils ont vu et quoi
et pas que ceux qui l'ont toujours
écouter ces gars là existe on est témoin
et on a fait un concert comme ça où tout
le monde et ça a été un choc après était
bon ces bons ne bougeait plus maintenant
avec une histoire aussi riche que la
vôtre est ce qu'il ya eu ce qu'on vous
conseille comme des grands moments des
choses dont vous vous souvenez qui vous
ont vraiment marqué là qui ont marqué le
groupe durant votre longue carrière
quelques grands moments
et en a mais moi moi celle que je peux
regretter c'est un peu après qu'on ait
pris un temps de pause pour créer cette
musique là on a fait le premier concert
qu'on a fait au sénégal
ça a été mal reçus parce que nous on
nous attendait avec on avait une rupture
de deux ans vous jouez de la variété la
musique sénégalaise ont été ses lèvres
et on est venu en mettant une autre
musique quitté très élaborés et donc des
gens ne se reconnaissaient n'était
rempli ses 8 ans on est revenu les gens
disaient qu'on allait retrouver le goût
et on a joué des premiers concerts 2 3
musique il y avait 1500 personnes à la
fin 4 et musique il y avait 10 personnes
parties et on a fait les cons servent
qu'à la fin après dans l'est dans les
loges on s'est dit mais c'est pas qu'un
lieu de décourager on se dit c'est pas
grave nous ont pas compris nous on va
ouvrir deux parties rester comme ça
qu'on est revenu chez nous mais sans
stress ça moi ça m'a surpris je me
disais et après quand on en parle
maintenant ça pourrait en décourager en
faisant finalement et or après ce qui se
passe c'est que deux mois après et à
hugh masekela qui est passé là bas qui
faisait une tournée et nour et à le voir
on a vu parce qu'on le connaissait
à travers une vidéo et on s'est dit il
faut qu'il nous écoute
le problème c'est que s'il devait partir
le lendemain et on s'est dit on à
talonner ou le dit mais il faut qu'ils
nous voient mais on avait pas de bombe
quoique ça c'est avec une voix à
l'iphone on avait préparé chez nous
notre salle devrait tous nous on s'est
battu avec une copine à nous j'ai dit
mais vient écouter ces gens là et dz
matin il a dit ok c'est certain c'était
un grand monsieur
et pourtant une grande star qui ne
connaissait pas évidemment je venais il
est venu chez nous des deux hommes matin
il s'est assis là dans la salle on a
fait le concerne lui au troisième
morceau il a dit stop
vous êtes des sénégalais vous
vous êtes la musique on a expliqué il a
dit ok les gars il est parti trois mois
après on a eu des coups de fil d'un
monsieur tu me disais bon ont été
invités au liberia où vous passez en 77
parce qu'il ya un grand concert qui aura
lieu c'est pour récolter des fonds pour
les exilés sud africains auront réfugiés
sud africains qu'ils étaient étudiants
aux états unis donc ils font un concert
il y avait mal dibango miriam makeba il
y avait le leader des black panthers qui
était venu et tout ce qu'elle a fait la
moue et élit les jeunes jean macé cra
avait pris le risque dix ans je vous
présentais dédain que j'ai trouvée au
sénégal les gosses et là aussi c'est là
où on a été respectée parce que tous ces
messieurs qui étaient là bas on parlait
un peu partout et je pense que cette
période là pour moi c'est la plus
importante c'est ça que les amener à
quoi s'est carrément petit livre quoi
payer les rencontres comme le concert
avec après partie des causes 18 19 ça
c'était un grand moment aussi dans notre
vie parce qu'on n'était pas attendu
c'était un public de crosby stills nash
wii party ça commence à être les débuts
des collaborations qu'on recense
aujourd'hui une à l'époque c'était
c'était drôle
on est parti faire les percussions dans
leur album de corneille
ça aussi c'était peut être un moment
très fort de chalabre et puis le fameux
festival de jazz de paris
on a eu tous les noms alors souleymane
est ce que les jeunes
l'ajout de la nouvelle génération
aujourd'hui consultent des gens comme
vous est ce qu'on essaie de prendre des
conseils auprès de vous pour
l'excellence dans la mer la musique
[Musique]
déjà ils reçoivent ou bien il se trouve
de l'eau
via toi je soulage d'écouter les gens de
taxes comme si tu veux parler des fois
c'est bon parce que vous êtes une
référence et c'est ce que ces jeunes là
viennent parfois vous demander des
conseils veulent oui séduit donc donc
vous faites baisser la demande est là
pour lui c'est incroyable et pour dire
par rapport à la musique en nous c'est
vrai que on est des écoles en blanc
il faut que j'aime chez toi il faut
montrer de change etc
et c'est vraiment fait il ya plein de
jeunes mamans qui chante qui ont changé
les idées de ceux qui la complète
l'écriture vous écris ça va c'est
vraiment l'icône de l'écriture tadic et
chanter parce que c'est pas évident
c'est à dire d'écrire en disant qu'on
fait un bouquin mais c'est de le chanter
d'une manière tellement c'est à dire que
les chansons qui sont il ya des
classiques qui à mon avis jusqu'à la fin
des temps indémodable parce que ça parle
de l'amitié il ya une chanson qui
s'appelle l'amitié c'est une chanson qui
culte en dos laisser le tout la
puissance en fait c'est tout montrer
qu'en fait quand tu es jeune
c'est là où tu peux tout préparer
l'avenir mais aussi il ya un message à
l'intérieur qui est tellement puissant
que les gens le prennent l'utilisent n'a
pas commis alors bon on vous qu'on le
voit au sénégal peut parfois en afrique
et a beaucoup de il ya une nouvelle
génération qui est en train de prendre
place il ya des gens qui vont introduire
ap qu'ils vont introduire le hip hop
dans les chansons dans le style africain
ya même des gens qui de plus en plus
voir les verts ce qu'on appelle le coupé
décalé en côte d'ivoire
alors vous avez puristes quel regard
portez-vous sur cette mutation la sueur
du style musical afrique en ce moment au
sénégal r e
moi je trouve qu'ils ont beaucoup évolué
être et voulait c'est seulement parce
que avec la technologie maintenant
rappelle bien pratique de s'exprimer et
est une musique qui est mouillé alcoa
qui tout le monde peut danser donc saf à
mon ami je suis très fier ok d'accord
parce que vous vous savez on a toujours
tendance à apprécier toujours ce qu'on a
connu surtout dans son enfance dans sa
jeunesse et tours et on sait aussi que
pour ce qui est du travail là où on vous
appelle des outils des instruments qui
sont beaucoup plus accessibles
aujourd'hui ça vous n'aviez pas ça
c'était le travail qui fait votre votre
point fort nous ne comptions pas sur des
instruments pour vous aider si jamais
des lacunes ici et là alors oui c'est à
dire en fait nous ont aidés en fait
c'est sa cornée précurseur et c'est bien
on voit par exemple les jeunes par
exemple moi je parle la musique nigérien
parce qu'on a vu au début comment ça se
passe et on connaît l'origine des
terribles un élève là le goumbé on ne
retrouve un peu partout et tout mais
d'arriver avec la technologie de créer
ce style qui marche pour tout commence à
envahir le monde
je suis désolé c'est à dire que on peut
connaître fièrement je suis désolé si je
préfère écouter ça que d'écouter des
musiques qui viennent de notre continent
ça vient d'eux c'est pas loin maintenant
on voit s'est adapté par tous les jeunes
au sénégal il ya des jeunes qui
utilisent cette rythmique qui est pas
loin de chez eux et y met des textes des
choses sympas c'est très positif dans le
sens où pendant des années nous ont ses
bagages
à faire des tournées à des voix là on a
une musique écoutez-vous ça se danse et
finalement le travail qu'on a fait là a
permis à nos jeunes fer où nos enfants
avec la technologie d'être créatif et
finalement à partir du coupé décalé que
c'était aujourd'hui dans toutes les
radios africaines avant qu'il y avait 99
% de musique europe et amériques m
aujourd'hui c'est exactement l'inversé
c'est 99% de musicologie voyait
congolais camerounaise c'est qu'alain la
culture en tout cas s'il ya quelque
chose qui se vend aujourd'hui on
n'influence le monde entier il ya aucun
problème
ou tu vois aujourd'hui tu en parles la
musique africaine avec cette jeunesse
qui sont très créatifs qui ont aussi
évidemment la place est facilitée de
pouvoir s'affirmer dans sa chambre sur
son lit écrit un morceau et que des
naissains pas bon ça c'est ce qui se
passe mais en même temps ils se trouvent
comme bien des gens comme nous parfois
ils viennent par nos vieux morceaux et
en faire quelque chose de nouveau un
neveu et c'est là où on se dit qu'on se
lève on le sait on est très fiers des
centres très fier de ça en tout cas pour
ceux qui sont à montréal et qui se
souvient de vous qui veulent vous
découvrir c'est ça va se passer à
montréal donc vendredi au national
un spectacle unique à montréal donc il
faut être là pour pouvoir apprécier ces
géants de la musique africaine
oui d'affaires il faut vraiment il faut
vraiment que toute la communauté tous
les canadiens viennent voit et ce qu'on
propose
et puis d'autant plus que c'est vraiment
une équipe de jeunes pratiquement dans
nos enfants qui ont ce qu'ils ont créé
ce label nous faire venir
les goûts comme nous c'est les jeunes
sénégalais qui sont là qui sont là bas
ils s'appellent mutuellement de
production des s 300 qui veut dire la
tradition 60 production radio phalange
dernièrement c'est la révélation là et
qui ont décidé de quand même promouvoir
la musique africaine
c'est pour ça moi je dis bravo et à la
communauté sénégalaise ici les nos amis
avec le président ça rompt avec tous ces
gens là et puis nos copains haïtiens
parce qu'on a beaucoup d'américains et
qui sont ici non on évite tout le monde
ne sait rien sur tous les canadiens et
les montréalais venez voir le talent
parce que nos premiers arbres ici en
amérique c'était à montréal au spectre
20 ans on est de retour
merci beaucoup d'être venu